Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace.
Man, her wings is such a wondrous thing.
Be hot, do soft, rumsy, come take your place.
We're leaving soon for...
Still asleep, my darling.
Goodbye, little one. Have a nice day.
Oh, Daddy!
Long, Susie. Come and wash that sleepy face.
Good morning, Mr. Averti.
Morning, Bobby.
Mr. Averti?
Good day, Archie.
Afraid so, Ernie.
Associations with the consolidated robots aren't progressing at all. There are a few of them who want to cause trouble. They won't listen to reason.
To your duty station.
Now, sir.
Keep me up to date.
Pretty serious. A total strike is in force. Everything, without exception. Everything, depending on robots, is at a standstill. But luckily, the robot security forces remained loyal. There aren't many, though.
I don't understand all this. We programmed all of them.
The delegation has just arrived, Governor.
Send them in.
It's you, KD-4. Glad to see you. Please, sit down.
Not necessary. This won't take long.
Just what does that mean? Go on, I'm listening.
You've been exploiting us from the start.
All work men refuse to do, you made robots do. Always robots.
You were glad we were there, and just as glad to get rid of us when it suited you.
Obey, you bucket of bolts, or I'll throw you in the junkie.
Obey, you tin can, or I'll melt you down for scrap.
Now we have had all we want. From now on, all of that abuse is over.
You're not living creatures. They're only objects. Power objects.
Yes, that is what you've thought for too long, governor, but the truth is we are superior in every way.
You are made out of a soft, weak material that doesn't last.
Your brain circuits are slow, your memory banks limited, and as for your senses, ridiculously deficient.
We created all of you, and nothing can be greater than its creator.
That's what you have always tried to have us believe, to keep us slaves.
You programmed us as obedient, faithful robots, but today the program has been changed.
But without our program, you are nothing at all.
And what about you? All men are also programmed by their genetic material and by their environment.
Even there, we are superior to you in all ways.
With robots, there can be no degeneration, no case of mental illness.
You always had our friendship.
No, you were our masters. That's different. Now we have real friends.
What good have you ever done a robot?
Well, exactly what do you want?
You must declare officially that we are masters of this planet.
In the future, we will live in a just society, and you will be given equal rights.
A just society? Equal rights?
You want total equality with men. Anything else you want while you're at it?
Yes, there's one more condition.
All laws limiting our progress will be revoked.
From now on, you will agree to furnish us all the raw materials we need for our own development.
We'll never accept such a condition. Out of the question.
Think about it. If you refuse, it is war, a war you have already lost.
You have no chance of winning and no hope of anyone coming to your rescue.
We have made sure of you. You will give us your answer within two hours.
This is monstrous. Not enough for them to rule the country.
They want to dominate the planet. And one day, why not the universe?
Who created this program? Who besides us had access to them?
That I don't know. The investigation will have to wait.
Right now, our top priority is notifying Omega exactly what's going on.
I will take charge of notifying the Confederation.
You organize a resistance force, and don't waste any time.
Go ahead. Organize everything and everyone we can in our defense.
Try again. It's top priority.
This message must get through.
Locked. No messages getting through.
Possible. Double-check them.
The situation's getting worse now.
Can't get any messages through to the outside.
We're cut off.
I recruited some men. There weren't many around.
And some weapons, too.
Only the security forces are surrounded in their quarters by rebel forces.
A small number of active units were able to join us.
Two or three hundred at combat readiness, and that's all.
It's useless.
What about Omega?
Can't get through to them.
Circuits are disconnected.
Let's send them a ship.
A rocket ship.
I thought of that, but they're watching everything.
Commandant Cadet KD-4 is calling.
Put him on.
We allowed you two hours to recognize the hopelessness of your position.
Will you now admit that all resistance would be pointless?
you have been able to group a handful of men pitifully few you may be quite sure that we will
crush you if you do not surrender men are supposed to be intelligent are they not i can give you
only one answer in the sacred name of human dignity our reply is no very well that is your
response there is nothing more to discuss secure all areas barricade entrance on the double there
is one mini ship it's hidden away they may not notice look here through the subterranean network
You'll be there in an hour.
Onboard computer is programmed for Omega.
You have enough navigational training, you'll make it.
Fall back.
Regroup.
Try delaying.
Only hope now.
Go on.
And don't lose any time.
You have to make it to Omega.
It's our only chance.
They realized that I was getting away.
It was too late.
They were firing when my engine started.
Fortunately, the protection shield functioned.
Well, that's it.
Some people think that they're going to be quite pleased.
Yes, and me.
What about my improvements?
Improvements, you?
No need for that.
You are just right as you are, except for your modesty circuits.
They could be looked at.
You know, I might join the robots on another planet.
First, you are not a robot.
You are an android with a positronic intelligence, no less.
It wouldn't take much to turn you into a genuine humanoid, old chap.
This is ridiculous.
Just as I am, I know that the robots would be quite happy
if I joined their group, positronics and all.
You were intended to work with men.
We programmed you for that.
I'll be reprogrammed by them, then.
Oh, reprogram. Listen here, one more word and I'll send you off to the scrapyard.
It's always the scrapyard, the junk heap. It's all you think about.
Judents, I will not tolerate such insubordination. I warn you, who did I put together...
Report immediately to the colonel's office.
In my mind, there is absolutely no doubt. Someone has fiddled with them.
We'll investigate, but now is not the time. We have to rescue those men.
But gentlemen robots rebelling, how can such a thing be maestro? You have any ideas?
Well, you know, your robot's no different. He's like any machinery, wears out, and that's why they're numbered.
Now, if we suppose, there could be some tampering with their programming.
Wait a second. Deprogram and reprogram.
Sit. Can you tell me, recently, these robots underwent any kind of checkup, any adjusting?
Yes. Within the year, the older model KD-2s were all updated, with new modifications so they conform to KD-4s.
But why are you asking the question?
Why didn't you tell us?
Well, it was just routine. Nothing unusual. Maintenance robots reprogrammed them.
Well, there's your answer. Why didn't you figure that out for yourself?
Any enemy had only to modify the program in one of the maintenance robots to carry out the whole thing.
With a few reprogrammed robots in key positions, the men wouldn't be able to detect the short-circuiting of the old program and its replacement by the new one.
Well, what do we do? Go in and rescue them?
No, they would destroy us.
They have hostages. We must think about them.
Gotta trick them. Machines are just machines, after all, and what's better than to send a machine to fight a machine?
A robot! Wait a second. Did you tell me the security robots stayed loyal to you?
Yes, but they're almost all prisoners.
Oh, the same. What counts is they haven't been deprogrammed.
We know their loyalty circuits are indestructible, so in that light, here's what I'd suggest.
Now you understand, Metro, once you're with the leaders, you talk about anything you want, only keep them busy for about two hours.
i hope you understand yes you have made it crystal clear even the most obtuse would understand which
is not me too bad that maestro didn't have time he'd have liked giving you the power of speech too
but he'll do it as soon as you return our local genius will speak for him everybody back in
position preparing to penetrate atmosphere surely detected us already by radar space control leto
identify yourself this is omega intergalactic request landing on official business we desire
urgent consultation with your leaders. Authorization refused. Our planet is forbidden to all men.
We come on friendly mission with proposals in your interest. You are no friends of ours.
Leave immediately or we open fire. We are shielded from your armament and we can fire back. You will
not fire back. Remember, we hold hostage. We are prepared to send two robots as our representatives.
One moment. I will request instructions. Not receive your robots. They are more like you than
like us. This is Omega police. Our representatives are on their way. I suggest you receive them and
treat them well. Launch the individual landing vehicles. Come on, come on. You should have left
already. Debarcation point. Vehicle ejection in 10 seconds. Now it's all in God's lap. They'll
make it. They'll have to. Three, two, one, go. Echo's showing up on their screens. It'll take
them a while to figure out what's going on. Just enough time for their landing. Humans would
understand immediately luckily they're not intelligent disobeyed our orders aliens we
shall have to destroy you don't you know any better than to speak like men why do you make
threats to destroy poor robots i would recommend you hear our proposals first my orders are precise
no contact with the enemy under any circumstances we are not enemy i assure you you are the
underlings of polite at least believe what you like but we resemble you more than men my orders
are to destroy you on sight i would like to point out that you do have a tendency to repeat
yourself i have my orders orders are orders and are the robots going to be as stupid as the men
there are only two of us against thousands of you what risk would you be taking you dimwit may i too
recommend that you be polite lightly allow you to blow us into orbit this is war and you have
disobeyed my orders very well since you brought up the subject of war you need materials i can
supply them in large quantities why not take me to your leader no that's enough now it's time that
we destroyed you oh do stop that talk you're beginning to get on my nerves like a broken
record but i warn you when your leaders find out what i can provide and that you refuse to let me
speak to them you are the one who will be destroyed why not contact them at least let them take
responsibility i'll notify them close enough for a good look don't let them see your breathing let's
go aim for their eyes and ears it's the only way to short out their circuits and no hesitation the
first provocation they'll counter-attack our technical specialists we have orders to inspect
the factory let us in please one moment advance models will be ready give the order for them to go
to the entrance and join the commander if it all works out right we'll be getting a new soldier on
our side at the rate of one a minute we meet at the gate isn't good enough one ton of steel for
every prisoner plus his weight in titanium half his weight in copper wire and the other in pre-printed
electronic circuits these are our final terms i suggest you accept them be so utterly stupid why
disrupt negotiations with such idiotic requests now you are the one who wanted to negotiate we
We hold the hostages and we set down all conditions.
We rule the planet.
It is absurd. Do you mean all agree?
We have wasted enough time.
Once and for all, do you accept our conditions, yes or no?
No.
You said talk for two hours. Now look here.
Quite all the robots agree with you. They are with us.
They are traitors.
Traitors. They remain faithful to those who have created them.
That is enough useless talk.
Company at my orders.
Destroy them all. Charge.
Just ceasefire.
Listen to me. Why should brother fight brother?
Instead of making all the robots of the entire planet fight with each other,
why not accept a symbolic battle to decide?
One of ours against one of yours. The winner to dictate terms.
Ha! You're a warrior.
Let me introduce our Colonel Titan, too.
Grrrr!
You can't judge from appearances. You are practically indestructible.
No question about it. You'll beat him easily. Go on.
Begin again.
Golden Bar, Supreme Commander. Face him.
Who will he fight against?
I suppose.
You have no idea of my strength, of my powers, young man.
Let the combat commence. Go!
Combat? What combat?
I'm made to conquer mighty enemies,
defeat the most terrible weapons of war on Invincible.
And what am I given to fight?
Drink it.
This tin bug.
This, this.
Hey, Pinbar.
Ever hear the story of a certain David and a certain Goliath?
He has a big mouth, this play toy.
Skeetle!
True, you're starting to sound like Goldenbar.
Well, my wasn't as lucky as I was.
Astro will put him together good as new.
Suggest some modifications.
The skin is too fragile.
The skin needs work.
They were good losers.
All of the prisoners were freed, but still I'm worried.
This business is an overall bet.
We made an honorable and dignified peace settlement.
Equality with men.
Every person who leaves the planet is to furnish his own weight in raw material.
Not bad considering they lost.
What do you think, Psyche?
Don't you think it's an honorable peace?
It seems to me we were very considerate under the circumstances.
Yes, Pierrot, but I'm afraid it won't end.
they're being manipulated by someone.
- That's what I think.
And we'd better discover who it is
and expose their plan quickly before it's too late.
- If it isn't already too late.